James is with us in Rochester Minnesota
hi James how are you I'm pretty good
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I'm uh well I got married
last year got your book as the person
never heard of you before that and then
uh I'm all on board my wife is left so
she's kind of just going along with it
but I mean she's not gizelle and I'm
willing to be hold on I'm 30 and she's
22 so she's kind of going through I
don't know a fun stage she makes twice
as much as I do a year and it's hard for
me to say no we can't go out for dinner
or no we can't go to the mall for a day
because she makes so much more than I do
so so you lost your ability to vote in
the household based on the economics
it's it that's pretty lame no I still
have a vote that I like it just is not
as long as hot as her mind she just got
two you got one it kind of that's that's
how I feel that's probably not how she
feels at all okay then stop seeing that
why because that's not a good way to
have a relationship but you should not
make decisions together based on who
makes the most money has the most votes
that's not a good plan especially when
one of you is 30 in the other ones 22
okay so you got a little more life
experience could we agree on that that's
right okay good and that's not to say
she's inept at 22 but in this case
apparently she is so in in this
particular subject so how are we gonna
do this you start talking about what we
need to do we don't need to go the mall
we don't need to spend so much money we
need to get out of debt you start
talking about what after you read my
book instead of talking to her about how
and why you need to sit down together
and dream and say what if we were out of
that what if we had no debt at all what
what if we had a million dollars what
would we do what could we do would we
travel would we give more generously to
causes what would we do if we had a
million dollars well what's the shortest
path to get to that dream of being able
to do those things
the shortest path is to live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else the shortest path is to
be debt-free and living on a plan in
adults devise and plan and follow it
children do what feels good it's a sign
of maturity to learn to delay pleasure
emotional maturity
whether you're 22 or 52 it's a sign of
emotional maturity and so this is how
you need to lead in your household you
need to serve your wife by helping a
dream be born for this couple and what
you're gonna be doing you need a big why
I think we're talking about what all the
time and because she hasn't bought into
the what because she doesn't have what
why somehow you got the why early in the
discussion now you got to transfer it
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]